now your character is this amazing fan
of these shortbread biscuits on ted
lasso and so when i heard that you were
gonna teach us a dessert i immediately
transported myself
to the biscuit journey in the show and i
thought
really you're gonna teach us the dessert
how perfect well i thought i would show
you something that i was shocked you
guys don't already know about
and that is the absolutely delicious
very naughty and very moorish eaten mess
well i love naughty i mean
honestly and this could you not just
stick your whole face in it
get in there okay
smooshed
smushed
meringue all smashed up to bits
you could even yeah you could even put
it in a bag and smack it against the
wall and get all your frustration out
but look at how this beautiful look at
it look at it i mean look at that
already i'd stick my head in that
already i mean i'm gonna stick my head
all in there
and then usually
i would just put like
the red berries in whatever basically
whatever you have in terms of berries
would be gorgeous in it
raspberries
yeah even blueberries blueberries are
yummy with it yes
yeah blackberries blackberries i don't
like so much because they're a little
bit tart they are right um look at that
already
but so here we have like fluff macerated
berries
look it's just got orange orange and
lemon and sugar and you just leave it to
just
do its thing marinate in its juices half
an hour
and then we're gonna stick this
i mean it's just
i can really taste the orange juice too
it's so perfect yeah exactly right oh i
need like this thank you that's a that
is a big gobspoon
that is a very civilized size spoon
i feel like this is just on i would just
have that oh
the whole bowl this spoon is just me
being myself oh seriously
that is the greatest spoon i totally
agree
right so oh you're still here
so we strip some of that in there
i'm gonna put that to that side so take
a little bit we're gonna try and look
like we're moving just use this bit
and stick a little bit of that
by the way these are beautiful they are
so pretty a nice wide stem they need a
gentle loving rehome
and then
let's take a little bit of that by
itself
mouthful
just to check it tastes nice on root
oh my god
i'm gonna create a little bit of that
like a little bit of a layer there
oh god it's so good it's ridiculous
where have you
where have you been all my life look
look at that
[Applause]
look drew
i'm not kidding i just want you to know
that like everyone on this show is
literally like oh my god there's two of
them
literally i think you and i were
like separated i know i do i know i have
to say when they said go andrew i was
like first of all i was like
first
couldn't get over myself living legend
that you are i feel so less alone in the
world right now having met you i do
i really do
look and then check this bit out get a
bit of the juicy dribble mmm juicy
dribble hashtag juicy hashtag dribble
oh
and then stick your face in the rest of
the bit that's in the bowl
isn't that just the best way to spend an
afternoon
oh my god it's so good my goodness well
um
please let this be the first of many
hangs and visits absolutely and as they
say in casablanca the beginning of a
beautiful friendship oh my gosh you've
made my day
you have to you've made mine
and we can like shame thou we can desert
make we can laugh we can talk about work
and motherhood and life and
mother working mothers oh my god shame
shame absolutely
it's like you have a kid and you
literally buy a house in this new town
called gilt city yep you do and you live
there for the rest of it i was gonna say
that i'm just trying to be fancy and
finishing off our little
you know garnish always sells i mean
yeah it always sells it but it's not
gonna be there for long
there we go
[Music]